three spanish dogs stranded in between
rivers of lava in la palma have vanished
they've been stuck for over a month
stranded and abandoned after the
kumbraviyeka volcano erupted the charity
and drone operator had planned to rescue
them by scooping them up in a big net
and flying them off to safety but when
they arrived at the scene the dogs had
disappeared all that was there were
footsteps and a banner that read be
strong la palma the dogs are safe a-team
both the charity and drone operator have
asked the mysterious rescuers for proof
that the dogs are safe and well but
they've yet to hear anything so are the
dogs safe and well